efectivamente como lo decías salió de la
agenda en una primer momento este tema
la petición conjunta de una nueva
arquitectura financiera que permitiera
que los países de la región de rentas
medias accedieran de forma más fácil a
los préstamos y a los créditos
internacionales sin embargo recordemos
que aquí las decisiones los puntos los
documentos no que se adoptan se adoptan
por consenso por lo tanto cualquier
pequeña discrepancia entre países puede
llegar a impedir que se adopte
finalmente una punto No firmado por
todos los jefes de gobierno y digamos
los jefes de estado sin embargo este
punto que como bien decías se había
caído de los borradores iniciales a los
que tuvimos acceso según nos han
comentado fuentes de la delegación
Argentina va a estar en la declaración
de Santo Domingo final que van a firmar
los jefes han estado y de gobierno de
aquí unas horas esto nos asegura la
delegación Argentina que tiene mucha fe
en alcanzar un compromiso es que
recordemos que en el discurso del
presidente argentino Alberto Fernández
ha enfatizado muchísimo en la necesidad
de reformar completamente
el sistema financiero internacional para
evitar los las enormes dificultades que
tienen los países tan endeudados como el
suyo también hemos hablado con la
delegación Argentina del acuerdo que
está sobre la mesa entre la mercosur y
la Unión Europea y si bien Argentina nos
ha dicho que hay bastantes dificultades
en el camino la Unión Europea se ha
mostrado más optimista Rosa también
varios presidentes han hecho sus
intervenciones en el transcurso del día
ya hablamos de algunos de ellos que
podría destacarse entonces de los demás
discursos
bien Daniela pues por ejemplo ha hablado
en nombre de España tanto el rey Felipe
vi como al presidente del gobierno Pedro
Sánchez quien ha abierto su discurso
haciendo referencia a la condena de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania un tema que no
ha generado unanimidad tampoco entre
todos los países presentes Pero ha dicho
que en este contexto de crisis total a
nivel internacional Estos espacios como
la Cumbre iberoamericana son más
importantes que nunca para fortalecer el
diálogo por otro lado también ha habido
muchos países que han remarcado la
importancia de que España vaya a asumir
la presidencia pro tempore del Consejo
de la Unión Europea Sí para acercar
ambas regiones a Chile ha sido uno de
los países digamos que ha pedido no más
Europa de hecho hemos podido escuchar un
poco entre pasillos los primeros
momentos de una reunión bilateral entre
josep borrell quien está aquí el alto
comisionado de la Unión Europea para las
exteriores con el canciller chileno no y
hemos escuchado estas mismas palabras
que pedía el canciller chileno aquí en
América Latina queremos más Europa entre
bromas sobre el litio Y por último una
cuestión que ha generado consenso
también entre casi todos los países que
han hablado ha sido una necesidad de
mayor integración regional ahora bien
muchos mandatarios han dicho que es
necesario pasar de La retórica a la
práctica No Petro sin ir más lejos ha
puesto el ejemplo de la Unión Europea
como ejemplo concreto de cooperación de
integración a regional y ya para
finalizar un tema que ha llamado
bastante la atención es que Costa Rica
ha pedido de facto que se materialice la
intervención militar en Haití ha dicho
que antes de pensar en cómo reformar la
casa antes de pensar en unas elecciones
en el país hay que apagar el fuego y que
el estado vuelva a tener control del
territorio